so no sympathy
let's see what card 82 had i don't think
i ever had from canada 21 38
and the kalashnikov
variant last time the controversial figure was
discontinued or went on the market or
something like that a little more careful wouldn't be
bad
so
yes i had that recently
I then took it on the lead hour
8 pulled I'll do it again I
couldn't imagine that should be
so great here refers to
the funny jumper and so
definitely needs a lot of time
eliminate back in the game has
so and I have yes  also not drawn b5 or
something like that
well white
actually plays here on c4 c4 c5
sometimes also fh zdf drawn here so
the question is whether you might
first draw b5 and then take it now
probably that's better
yes it's a weakening but
I don't know if he now goes to e 3
or d2 then he would have to
hit here somehow with the toom oh that's how
he wants to
jumper 15
yes I understand
well okay but I still have to
take so I do
so
maybe even a way
to f5
so
bishop fulfilled could still 15 well but
jump there still has to go
like that and now bishop f6 now I really
have your
5s too  nice figure
and he doesn't have a player anymore because he
can fly in somewhere here
so the question is now springer c4
directly
you can win material with it
i don't see what speaks against it at the moment
maybe the three can do it and
give the quality
yes but then thought  i said now
play
it really takes a while
until then threatened
so i can take the
how does vienna actually look like build more vienna
so
yes the quality i would like now
actually
only six more or so yes
could be compensation but i can
too
i could also play springer your film
then exchange a little something
at least if he draws the queen now
i could  also take this one out here
yes or this
order now i only have one
more pawn
but the runner is of course
very strong on your five
i don’t actually walk here
anymore
so you could calculate but now
i say he actually has five
so
yes me  I assume he will then put
a lot of people on the line again,
which I was, I can
maybe once again
from a safe field, offshoot c3
, too, that was the idea, yes, but that's
just a shadow,
so some people have to be careful, it will be
here  When it comes to processing, of course I
have unequal runners here, so you have to be
careful that
you keep a little something on the board
, so if only the runners
remain, it is certainly not
easy to win, if at all
possible,
another possibility may
also be
here in the long term  attacking yourself
with f 4f 3, for example, i mean
i no longer have a pawn on the
kingside and the runners  fern 5 the
main problem is actually god what
do i have then there exist
tell i did
n't even pay attention to a faster
got to me 5
yes
loudly c4 actually had an idea
yes one should have
thought about it a bit more now  just set
a february now
unfortunately thome also had six if he had
to swap now then i would
still have a bit of residual hope as i
mean it's still one figure
less but
then it doesn't look good anymore
if i still don't have
it so well  well
super dramatic then that doesn't
make
sense for him i mean the player a little bit further maybe you still get pawns somehow but well of course it was unnecessary
before was a smooth
winning position like i now didn't win the pawns
between so to speak
so i have two  Farmers
are still broken but
yeah
cicek well
well
now it's getting slow but
if that's a lot
well well
often like that  I think I can move faster
yes I also won over time
over time of
course I was allowed five I of
course didn't see it before
it was just one more pawn for nothing